thank you very much for attendance talk
and I hope everyone here brought your
team for your hat for this talk so did
you ever wonder why organizations
companies or even that government's try
to that analyze you and not get to the
Internet and how they are still able to
do that even when you disable cookies in
your browser
you know default browser for example so
in this talk we'll try to cover a little
bit about the whole history of the
fingerprints on the web environments in
the browsers and towards the end we are
going to talk a little bit about more
like more advanced and fingerprints
techniques but and also like how or
tries to mitigate them by the way I said
try because secrets basically a cat
mouse game and attackers are in a
constant pursuit to circumvent our
fingerprinting protections so it's a no
end game and normally the user always
lose and the final thing I'm going to
say at first going to start talk is I
couldn't say the word attacker a lot so
when I say the word attacker we can
think about anyone who tries to dine on
misers like could be a company a tracker
advertising anything like that so that's
it so like I said before I work for
desktop browser mainly work on the
mobile stuff I work a little bit with
the fingerprinting perhaps bypass so if
you have any question about a browser
any complaining feel free to stop by and
ask anything about or so before like
talk about track we need to understand
what is the motivation like in the
security world it's it's common before
talking about defense and attacks we
need to think about the attackers
mentality so we need to know why people
want to attack the user want to dynamize
the user so store developers we have
like we have a design document and we
think those are the mainly
kind of goals of the attackers the first
ones analytics so people want to know
organizations want to know what the
users doing how many times a unique user
access of the website so it is why
people normally do analytics target ads
personalization so sometimes a company
wants to have a handcraft wants to send
the user handcraft experience so it is
and by the way not over Evo some things
make sense but we really believe in like
lawful concerns fraud detection in the
anonymization the day anonymization
probably the most evil of them because
they normally are made by dictatorships
trying to the non mais descents so these
are the main goals of a tracker
attackers but before talking about
fingerprint techniques on understand why
the fingerprint techniques are more and
more advanced at these days and one of
the motivations because of the cookies
so I love this like Scott from LA Times
from our article from the 1996 where
it's a scooter nuggets of data that can
be stored in your PC by a website in the
in the excess that every time you go
back to that website and the interesting
thing about Scott's because they says
that site the concept of third party was
not that clear at that time so again it
was self-contained to a single party to
a single site and the idea of cookies
are really simple probably everyone
knows here how cook the words and so the
first step the user browser requests a
web page the server sends back the page
and the cookies using the such cookie HP
header and finally when the users
accessing a page from the same website
so this the server knows the user had
visited that page simple it's easy but
what happened after the cookie was
created was people were able to
attack users they were able to track
users special like advertisers and
truckers and they did that because
cookies are really easy to reason about
anyone can understand how cooks wards
and anyone can play a round of cookies
so in 996 third party cookies were being
used everywhere so in 1996 double-click
was also created so was launched at as
company one of the big gas truckers
advertised in the world bought by Google
by the way and how part how that part
cookies works is almost the same the
main difference is now in your page you
have an advertiser their normal embedded
not iframe so the iframe lives in
another party in an overt you know the
domain the user sends a request to the
to fetch all the contents from the
website the advertiser and the content
websites the server sends the content
plus the advertiser and the advertiser
also sets a cook but when you go to
another website the divert Iser reads
that cook and they know what kind of
thing what kind of sites did you visited
for so it's a good example created by
goons in on his life our deities
call it online track technology and
privacy a it explains for example
sometimes you're accessing a news
websites and later on you can assess a
health website searching for outside
more cancer or something like that
and now they're advertising knows what
you are doing
so the concept of that third party poop
is in your lives two days but a few
people felt not so help about that like
for example the ad blockers and they
start to create a bunch of other
blockers we have private badge you have
pom pom pom opt lake from EF f at the
block grocery so a bunch of ad blockers
try to prevent third party cookies
however
what happened was preventing cooks is
not enough anymore you need you need
change how the browser behaves to have
real privacy stays because JavaScript
CSS HP headers how they should be
protocol behaves everything like expose
the user locality let's try
besides the user locally it's expose the
users machine what kind of machine I am
it's it's exposed what language the user
navigates on internet so Otto's tools
are amazing but they are not enough
right now they are in luck if you want
real privacy they are not enough so
let's talk a little bit about browser
fingerprints the tor browser have like i
said before we have a document a design
document documentation where we talk
about what kind of fingerprint attacks
trackers advertiser documents tries on
the users and then me four of them
request behavior javascript attackers
CSS attackers and plugins we're not
going to talk about plugins because if
you are using plugin you are a red screw
it sorry so the first one it's the most
simple one is the request behavior
attack and basically it is when you are
requesting content from a server and
it's mainly about the accept headers and
user agents there are others but they
are the others are more in the HTTP
laughs hm connection level people are
able to do Namas you base it on the HTTP
specification but this one are the most
simple one so a good examples except
language so a trucker or advertiser
knows you are English speaker if you say
intercept language English us or
accepting coding so there's acting codes
interesting because every browser has a
different accepting coding
and so a trucker truckers or Moe air
people malware suckers they know what
browser you are and can provide you more
malware specific exact pose for you in
the user agents this is user agent
effects from the tour so every time you
access websites the website thinks you
are a Windows machine so it is why that
is Windows NT so it's from the past and
we'd never change that the other one is
now think more about javascript
javascript is really interesting because
it's a amazing language it allows you do
anything and everything and from the
security side when you do everything
anything it's terrible so I don't know
if you you every user tor browser and
desktop browser there's a thing called
add secured slide one components a
political slide you can change how much
safe
you weren't for example the default
option Java scripts enable you are able
to play video you are able to play audio
but when you move up a little bit to the
safe to a more safe or privacy things
are too we start to disable things from
the browser start to disable JavaScript
we start to disable video we start to
save on audio and going to explain a
little bit why so the first thing is the
navigate object the window dot navigate
or objects this one this object exposed
so many things like for example in this
example that suppose my language even
expose what part for am I so when I took
the screenshot I took from my macbook so
it's it says in the platform Mac Intel
so attacker is able to know I am in
MacBook and it's scary really scary
especially like if you are I don't know
in Iran we're all like a turkey these
days is also crazy so it's really scary
JSS pose that much information other one
is GS all other DJ's object who suppose
our formations the screen one
so the problem about the screen is
because when you are a mobile or when
you are you're not booked when you are
mobile specially Android Android has so
many screen dimensions sometimes you you
are able to know what's the specific
device base on the screen so on this
example we are showing like the whole
screen for same MacBook and also that
pixel that is also really scary
you should never suppose that so we we
try to educate that like make the values
be uniform there is two kinds of
mitigations lot of researchers explain
the papers the first one is make
everything uniform all the users should
have the same values so which it's the
same of it's the approach you use on per
browser and the other one is make some
noise each like user is going to have a
different value we don't do that because
it's a little bit hard to do that like
to do that without adding issues to the
browser because every time you access
something it's been nature at the noise
and can be it can make a we chemical
issue so we make like Loki owes dates
van doors we try to make everything
uniform so for example dates if you are
if you are using a browser and you stand
Shea the data object and see what's the
current state of the user you are going
to see all of them are in the you'd see
zero or if they are in the Greenwich so
we try to normalize everything when you
show the same door all the vendors are
the same we try to bundle the language
inside the browser so to normalize
everything all the phones we burned all
the phones together for the browser to
make the same across everywhere so we
try to make everything uniform so the
second one is the web value the Web
Audio is amazing it's amazing PI like I
remember to went was release it and the
gamer developers they were like insanely
amazing about that because they were
able to do a bunch of stuff however
since
2016 2015 few researchers sergeant knots
how do we play the few websites however
not be played like the user is able to
hear the audio but we play in the
background and the notes like web value
was being used to track users but why
the first thing is the outer context so
every time every time you need you
create a web Yahoo object you must wait
every time you're going to use web value
you must create our outer context the
other part that exposed some information
about your machine and some of them are
unique even if you have two Mac books
from the same year but in the same day
they are unique for example the bass
Leighton's is totally different from
machine to machine the current time is
also different from machine to machine
what not what is not unique the
destination like sometimes they have
chose the number is the same and other
things are the same across machines but
one single object can expose some
information about the user so we try to
normalize a little bit as well and that
is other and this one is the most scary
one so basically this graph is when I
play one single audio but the users not
able to hear I just created out of
context and play that so the the blueish
line is it's a bassline created by the
experiment and the red line it's red
curve it's my machine so one machine is
different for the machine doesn't matter
if again if it was bought in the same
day but in the same place I was released
it has the same configuration it machine
is different from other machine so when
you play this audio you can see
difference between them so this this
block here this visualization was
created using these codes this code was
in the previous slide that is a paper
and this board of code was taken for
that paper and the codes really really
simple it's basically create an answer
creators later and playing playing that
like after that you just get the data
get the frequency and the frequency is
different for each user
so an even worse each not just each
browser but each browser version is
different so if I play this code in
Firefox I don't know
59 in Firefox 60 there are totally
different values so so like Web Audio is
insanely crazy to fix all the issues
from the web browser so we decide to
disable it's like it's it was almost
impossible to make it uniform without
breaking the whole user experience and
now probably is the most interesting of
them because it's so simple to explore
and so many people explore that is the
time based child side channels one thing
about javascript is like I said for the
CPU you can get the same CPU the same
chip it was being made in the same day
they were going to have few difference
so Java scripts really complex
JavaScript has a just-in-time
the memory management each jaw each
engine is different and JavaScript runs
on top of the CPU because of the
JavaScript just in time based on that we
are able to know how long a function
takes to run and fingerprint that so a
good example of that is Otto's functions
here we are able to calculate the
difference between where function runs
and use those functions to calculate
that so a good example is this block of
code is really really simple it's
basically so it was written by intro
boards in 2007 so it's not something
here like time-based side channels are
known for like years years and years and
example basically they they want to know
how long then next works back in the
browser err result when the image source
is not image for example in the line 9
if we look at the nine-nine line 9 they
test the source and at image
so with this code we know how long the
browser like the JavaScript sends this
URL to the network stack the networks I
do a lot of computations and phase-outs
saying okay this is not an image so like
it's a really simple code and there is
we can do kind of thing stretch prevents
kind of attack and the thing we do we
try to remove granularity we clamp the
difference between timers we claim to
100 milliseconds so if you get the
performance performance dot now and
should be tracked by other performance
but now the minimum value will be 100
milliseconds it's the best you can do
because everyone agrees side channels
time based side channels are terrible
and ideally we should remove any timer
from JavaScript however it's not
possible it would break the whole web so
it's one alternative we do we try to
clamp the value and it's - it's worth
rinsable but again it's not a super
Berlitz like we know someone can explore
that people like bad intention that
people are able to spur that like even
increase a little bit more the timer but
like for the majority of the attackers
it works the other things that converge
today the curve should is also like a
realtor saying because each browser has
a different graphics library and each
graphics library even for different
operating system renders differently so
the canvas to the attack basically
renders a bunch of things on the screen
using the few tags few style few
rat-free react and use the two data URL
to get that data to get that image and
say into a server like and so this image
is basically a key in a hash map so we
try different approach which gets that
but sadly we move its compact to the
user so in this example i try to access
the html5 canvas tutorial
it shows a pop up on my screen say okay
these users try to extract each and I'll
confess image from you from your browser
and you you like you cannot not allow
you can allow so it's remove its
contacts to the user it was the best
thing we could do we could do about that
like that attack I think Mozilla
experimenting a little bit like Mozilla
is also using the same idea they are
experiment a little bit but right now
they are kind of following the same idea
as well now talking a little bit about
CSS the interesting property that
trackers are able to fingerprints the
line hides so line Heights basically
there's they're centered at the center
and the okay and the font size so but
feel for different machines those valves
are different expression on Firefox so
on Firefox if you get the line height
from if you get the default line height
so for Linux is 90 pixels for Mac OS is
19.53 close and for Windows sometimes is
19 by 19 dot you or trainee so but why
it's happening it's because fonts are
broken
phones are terrible and really hard to
create a French really hard greater font
and each each like each machine each
each browser interprets system has a
different default fonts and each font
has their official so it is why on
Firefox when it's used the the font from
the system the font from plate system
the line Heights difference so we also
try to unit to uniform that so we much
instead the default value being their
Center plus that Center plus the font
size we multiply by one point show it's
what double Tracy recommend so we are
following the specification atleast but
again it's it's not amazing ideally it
should be fixed on the font size instead
of in the fonts platform sides instead
of browser side and talking a little bit
more about CSS we have the media queries
media cars are also able to track you
like the the properties we have like the
Deaf devices fact creation of device hi
its advice we added an image track the
device the machine the user's machine
side device size so what we do we also
uniform those values so the default
respect to racial puts the 1.0 we create
for the width too high we also make the
in uniform so if someone tries to know
what's the size of your device like when
si sizes mean size of your advice we lie
to the requester so and the last thing
is I didn't talk about it was we do also
something about cookies and Mozilla code
that first part is relation what we do
and we are a little bit more fancy we
call cross or identified only capability
trademark and basically is it is elates
all the identifiers source by URL
what are they identify source cookies
shared workers blob storage so for
example when you are accessing our
website and this website has a ads
inside the iframe iframe we isolate this
ad just inside that iframe all the
cookies all the shared workers of the
blobs of the storage canvas WebGL will
like try translate everything visit the
URL so the URL is a key to an identified
source it's look simple however it's
break the whole web when you enable that
so it is why I'm Mozilla doesn't a bad
fault because when you enable first by
relation one of browsers lot of
front-end programmers they won't be able
to communicate across the whole domain
and with first isolation we don't we
don't allow that anymore
thank you guys